So far in this playlist, I have taken a
lot of decisions and prescribed a lot of
ways of how a back end or an application
should be built and I have never really
stopped to defend them. For example, why
configuration goes in environment
variables, why the server binds a port,
why logs go to the standard output, why
processes have to be stateless, and why
when you kill a process, nothing should
be lost. A lot of these decisions in a
lot of videos. So today now that we are
approaching the end of the playlist I
want to show where a lot of those
decisions are coming from and a oneline
answer to that is it's called a 12
factor app. It's basically 12 rules that
was written in sometime 2011 by the
people who are running one of the first
cloud platforms which is Herio. To
summarize it in two sentences, a 12
factor app is a contract between your
application, your back end and the
platform that runs your application. It
states what must be true about your app
so that any machine, any platform and
any new teammate of yours can run it,
they can scale it and they can update it
without any kind of surprises. Every
platform that you will ever deploy to
today, they assume they expect that you
follow all these rules directly or
indirectly. For example, it all started
with Hioku. They started expecting
assuming it first. Why? Because they
wrote it. They wrote the original 12
factor app document. Then Docker also
assumes it. Kubernetes also assumes it.
Render, Railway, Fly, Cloudr Run,
AppRunner, Versel, Netlifi, does not
matter what cloud platform that you're
using today. They all in some parts they
assume that you follow these rules and
some of these rules have become so
common as a standard practice of our
development that people don't really
refer to the original source like
Telactor app when they are following
these practices. They just know that
these are the rules that you are
supposed to follow. This is part of your
development which is a good thing. It's
a good thing because it has become such
a standard that you don't need to
remember that it is a rule. It's just
how things work. So for example, when a
platform says that we inject
configuration through the environment or
when they say write your logs to the
standard output so that we can collect
them. All of these things that is coming
from these spread rules or the source
document. If you follow these rules,
these 12 factors, then every one of
those platforms, operating in every one
of those platforms becomes very easy
because instead of fighting with them
for all these standards, you are already
sticking to the standards which they
expect in the first place. This video is
uh partly a history lesson but it is
also a map of the contract that you are
already following but we are just giving
it a name giving it a concrete presence
so that you have a better mental model
of thinking about the whole
architecture. So before we start we need
to define the scope as usual. This
document this 12 factors app document.
This is about apps that run as a service
for example web apps, APIs or anything
deployed somewhere that can be reached
over a network by the internet and it
can be in any language. It can use any
database or any kind of queue. It does
not matter. Things like desktop software
or mobile apps, those are out of scope
for this video because this is primarily
about back end which are primarily
services. The list of the 12 factors,
they are mostly about the interface
between the application and the platform
it is running on, they are not a list of
uh everything that is good in your
software. For example, principles like
dry which means do not repeat yourself
or kiss which means keep it stupid and
simple something like that they are not
the factors. Similarly, we will not make
this video about uh Kubernetes
operations or micros service
architecture. None of that. We will stay
focused on the topic itself which is
understanding 12 factors themselves
without going too deep into any of the
branches of that. Now coming back to who
exactly wrote this document and why you
should take them seriously. This
document was written in 2011 when Hioku,
one of the first and most famous cloud
deployment platform as a service
platforms, they were around 3 years old
at that point. Uh by the way, platform
as a service means that you give the
platform your code and they take care of
the rest which means taking that code
and building that code, preparing your
environment, your configuration, your
connections to your database, your
networking needs, everything until your
application is live on the internet. It
is reachable by anyone who types the
domain name. That is what a platform as
a service does for you. And since they
were in that business, in the cloud
platform business, they were in a very
good situation or in a very good place
to notice all these patterns and
document them so that the rest of the
industry can also benefit from the same
patterns. The Hioku team, they probably
have watched hundreds and thousands of
apps and code bases getting deployed,
scaled, breaking in production and
getting corrupted across a lot of
languages and a lot of frameworks. That
is exactly the kind of visibility that
they got which enabled them to write
such a impactful standard such an
impactful document that we are still
talking about after all these years. So
Adam Wiggins one of the Hioku's
co-founders he wrote all those patterns
as 12 factors and published them at
12factor.net in 2011. Now to understand
why this document needs to exist or
needed to exist at that time, you have
to remember what deploying an
application, deploying any kind of
service was like at that time. Some of
you were probably around that time. Most
of us including me, we were not
developers at that time. So we can only
read from people's experiences. So this
is what it looked like. You anyone who
wanted to deploy their app over the
internet, this is what they had to go
through. They had to rent a server or
even worse, they had a physical machine
in their offices because even though AWS
existed back then, it was not as common
as of a standard that it is today. Cloud
was not as of a standard. people still
operated from their local servers.
Servers that were actually physically
present in their premises. So they
either rented a server through some
service whatever was popular during that
time which did not have all these
features that we have today or they had
a physical machine somewhere in their
premises. Then someone would install the
operating system by hand something like
Ubuntu or whatever Linux operating
system they wanted to host their server
in. Then they would have to install the
language runtime by hand because
whatever language they have written
their service in whether it is Java or
Go or Python the operating system would
have to have that runtime to run the
service. Then the database has to be
installed and some other supporting
libraries. Then the application itself
would have to be copied into the machine
sometimes using FTP which is called file
transfer protocol which is very famous
for any kind of development work during
that time. Then people would edit some
kind of config file on the server itself
manually using a protocol like SSH.
Every server that was built like this,
people would call these as snowflake.
Why? Because all of them were unique.
They were handbuilt and they were
impossible to reproduce because all of
that was done manually step by step by
some engineer. So if some other engineer
tries to reproduce the same steps even
through a documented manual there is a
very high chance that something will go
wrong or something will go different in
any of those steps. If you are trying to
execute all those operations by hand and
even after doing all this if the machine
dies for some reason then you'll have to
again start from scratch either from
memory or if you have documented it then
the manual. Similarly, if someone hired
a new developer into their team, then
just getting started with the codebase
with the running app with an instance of
the app running on their laptop, it used
to take days and even after that the
instance that was running in their
laptop, that did not match what was
running in production. And that is where
this famous phrase called it works on my
machine got popular and people used to
schedule their time for any kind of
deployment work by freezing any other
work that any of the team members were
doing. And this document the 12 actors
document it has a name for like this for
an app that is built and operated like
this. It is called software erosion.
Erosion basically means that the app
eventually and slowly it stops working
even though no one else changed any
code. Why? For example, imagine
scenarios like uh the operating system
gets patched with a new release after
you update your Linux distribution
whatever you are using. Or maybe the
same server is hosting two different
apps and the other app updated a library
which started affecting or breaking the
second app. Or if the person who
installed or maintained all these
complex infrastructure, they leave the
company and they did not really document
every single step or every single change
that they did on the app and on the
infrastructure which is very much
possible. It is impossible to track down
every single change that you're making
especially if you're making it manually.
So all in all these 12 factors are your
defenses so that your software your
application your infrastructure is not
exposed to erosion. One note before we
start with the 12 factors in the whole
video is for 13 years this document was
frozen. In the footer you can see that
uh it says last updated 2017 and that
update itself was also very small and
while the document was frozen a lot of
changes happened in the developer
ecosystem a lot of technologies were
introduced and got popular things like
containers kubernetes serverless and
managed cloud infrastructure everywhere.
So in November 2024, Hioku, which today
is owned by Salesforce, they open
sourced this document. They moved this
document into a public repo under a
neutral organization and they wrote a
governance document and they invited
maintainers from other companies
including from AWS and Google cloud so
that the whole community can revise it
and improve it and bring it to today's
standards. This is from Hioku on stage
at CubeCon November 2024 announcing the
same thing. The 12 factor app is now an
open-source project and the community is
invited to revise it and that revision
is happening right now in public on a
branch called next. It still keeps all
the 12 names and all the 12 oneline
motors, but it rewrites every factor
into a numbered list of principles and
separating the timeless principles from
the 2011 era and the modern principles
which is more applicable to today's
applications. As of today, the day I'm
recording this, the live site still
shows the classic 2011 text and the
rewrite is still unmerged and still a
working draft. So that's why for every
factor, I will talk about the original
2011 text first because that's where it
all started and then we will also see
what the community's rewrite is changing
about it. what is more relevant in the
modern times so that we get the history
and also the modernized version of the
same principles. So what is the plan for
this whole video? We walk through all
the factors, all the 12 factors one by
one and for each one we'll see what it
says in plain words, what exact problem
that it was trying to fix and where have
we already seen this pattern in this
playlist.
And after that what exactly the rewrite
changes in that. We will also see what
are the factors that aged well that are
still relevant and what aged badly which
means that it did it does not apply to a
lot of things today. So with that the
factor one which is one code base
tracked in revision control and many
deploys. There are two parts here. First
one codebase tracked in revision control
which is the one that is very obvious
today because we cannot imagine our
development workflow without a tool like
Git and uh GitHub, Bitbucket, GitLab,
whatever that you're using as a service.
But Git is the tool that pretty much all
of us depend on every single day, every
single hour of every single day. But it
was important to write it down. it was
important to document it in 2011. So you
have to think about the situation about
the scenarios during those times because
a lot of the production servers that
were written during those times they
still were just a folder on someone's
computer or a zip file with a name like
final v2 really final zip. So it was
important to make this a rule so that
people would treat it as a standard and
not keep their code in a folder and zip
their teammates through email. The
second one is the not so obvious idea
which is called many deploys. A deploy
that is the terminology here basically
means one running instance of your
application of your service. Production
is a deploy, staging is a deploy and
similarly these days we also have some
advanced workflows like a separate
exclusive deploy per APR but primarily
speaking a lot of teams still follow
production and staging but the idea is
same code base different deploys and
what exactly makes them different it's
not the code it's never the code even
though there are scenarios where the
production is running an older commit as
compared to the staging which is already
running the uh latest version of the
code. That can happen. But the point
here is all the commits are in the same
repository. They are not separate code
bases. But something here has to differ
between production and staging. It
cannot be code. So what exactly is it
that has to be different? Because in
your production it talks to a real
database while in local development we
start local containers of uh docker
posgress so that our back end can talk
to that and the code that we are running
in our local and the code that is
running in production they are still the
same. So the thing that makes them
different is config. That's the part
that makes every deploy different. So
code is one thing which is shared by
every single deploy but config is the
one that is unique to each deploy. Let's
say your applications repository is at
commit number 100 and let's say your
production instance that is currently
live on internet [snorts]
that is running the commit 97 because we
deployed let's say last Friday which was
3 days ago. Similarly, the staging
instance which is only accessible to
your internal team that is running the
commit number 99. Why? Because we are
still testing the code that is going to
get released tomorrow. But your laptop
runs the commit 100 plus the two commits
that you have not pushed yet. So four
different deploys but one codebase. Now
what happens on the deployment day?
staging moves to 100 then production
moves to 100. Nothing about the deploys
themselves changed except which commit
of the same repository each one is
running at one point. So the takeaway
here is if you cannot describe your
environment as a commit as the same
codebase at these commits then the
pattern is going wrong somewhere and you
are going to face issues in the future.
The factor also talks about two
boundaries which are if your system is
multiple code bases that is not
considered an application that is a
distributed system made of different
applications and each one of those
applications should follow the 12
factors on their own. Similarly, if two
applications share the same code, not in
the sense from the same source by code
sharing but by copy paste, then that is
also a violation because shared code
should get refactored into some kind of
library and it should be used through a
dependency manager which is a point from
factor 2 but worth a mention here. So
where does it stand in 2026? The one
place where it gets argued a lot is
monor repos which is a very popular
architecture these days because many
companies they keep a lot of apps in one
repositories and a lot of people
interpret this factor as monor repos
being an antiattern which I do not agree
because if you look at the definition
again which says a codebase is a repo a
repository or any set of repositories
which shares a root commit and the way
to test it is one to one between the
codebase and the app. So as far as this
factor is concerned about if a monorreo
builds five different apps then it is
the same as five different code bases
which happen to live in the same
repository but each one of them have
their own 12 factors. What it actually
restricts, what it actually considers as
a bad pattern is same app existing in
two places not the other way around
which means the copypaste sharing of
code that is the antipattern here. Then
comes factor two explicitly declare and
isolate dependencies. Two important
words there declare and isolate.
Declaration means that somewhere in your
repository there is a file which lists
completely and accurately every library
that your app depends on that your app
needs to run in your environment. And we
already know these files not from a rule
but by how we work. So if you work in
NodeJS then the file is package.json. If
you work with Go, the file is go.mod. If
you work with Python, then it can be
something like requirements.txt or pi
project depending on which tool you are
using. If you are in Ruby, then it can
be a gem file. What problem does it
solve? If you don't have this file which
we also call as a manifest file then
let's say talking about your local
environment if you get a new laptop or a
new teammate joins your team and if they
want to set up your whole application if
they want to run it then they have to
dig through the whole codebase they have
to read every single import statement
and they have to guess which versions it
should run and the versions themselves
have clashings between them, a lot of
issues, it can easily become a 2 to 3
days of constant setup operation. But if
you have this file, if you have this
manifest file which lists all the
dependencies with the right versions,
the pinned versions, then setting up the
whole machine to start your instance is
just one command which automatically
pulls, downloads all the packages,
installs it and gets your app running.
In the 2011 version, it mentions the
popular manifest files of those times
which is gem file because Ruby on Rails
was very popular during that time. So a
gem file with bundle installed and these
days the idea has become even stronger
because we not only have these manifest
files which are package.json,
god
etc. We also have log files to exactly
pin the versions not just have a range
of versions. So we have package log.json
go sum file and so on. Why? Because the
manifest file something like
package.json or go domod it it does not
really it it does not say precisely
which version of the package it wants.
It says it roughly needs a list of these
packages. But if you have a log file
then it pins the exact version of every
library and every libraries libraries
which means the libraries your libraries
also depend on to run themselves. So
even if you run your application which
has a manifest file and a log file after
months or years it is still going to
pull and run the same versions. Now
comes the second part of that phrase
which is isolation. Let's say we are
talking about Python here and we have a
popular library called requests in
Python for making HTTP related
operations. Your manifest says your
requirement.xt says that it needs the
requests library version two but your
app runs against the systems installed
Python where some other tool has already
installed requests version one. And when
you try to import it, the import
statement finds the systems copy first.
So even though you had the manifest, you
still did not achieve your expected
result. Your app still ran something
else than what you expected. So
basically declaration and isolation
themselves still break. If you just
declare but but do not isolate, you
cannot expect it to work everywhere.
Similarly, if you just isolate but there
is no declaration, then you are going to
spend your days and weeks trying to
reproduce the same version which you
might or might not achieve. Declaration
is something that is still very natural
because it is part of our workflow.
Without it, we cannot start working or
function in our day-to-day. But
isolation is something that is very easy
to forget which states that nothing
should leak from the machine because
declaring just your dependencies is
pretty useless if your application
ignores it and just uses whatever is
installed and available in your system.
For example, in the 2011 text, they
mentioned for Ruby it should be bundle
exec and for Python it should be virtual
env so that you achieve isolation and
they only see your declared
dependencies. Similarly, they also talk
about vendoring tools, which means let's
say you have an app that resizes images,
a backend app or service, and it uses
shell commands to use whatever image
magic binary version that your system
has, which is a very popular binary to
resize images. And on your laptop, which
is let's say a Mac OS, and you used
Homebrew to install your packages. So,
Homebrew installed image magic version 7
where the main binary is called magic.
But on the Ubuntu server, a installed
image magic version 6 where the binary
is called convert which has a different
set of defaults. So the same set of
code, the same snippet of code, it uses
shell command on both the machines but
they both do different operations
because they are two separate programs
since version six and version 7 since
they are major versions they will have a
lot of breaking changes a lot of
different behaviors. Now comes the
modern rewriting which is one of the
biggest turn of behavior when it comes
to the tech ecosystem which is
containers. So containers completely
change the power and scope of this
factor because if you take a docker
image then it not just freezes your
libraries but it also freezes your
operating system and your system tools
and the runtime itself. So that is the
peak of declaration and isolation that
you can ever achieve. This is why people
say that docker practically solved this
factor. Now comes factor three which
says that store config in the
environment. One of the most quoted and
most argued topic in the ecosystem. But
first what exactly counts as config?
Config is basically everything that is
likely which we have already discussed
when we were talking about deploys. So
config is something which is likely to
be different between different deploys.
For example, if we talk about the
database connection, the database URL,
then when it is running in your laptop,
it is connected to your local host to a
database which is running in a container
inside docker. But in production, it is
connected to let's say Amazon RDS
through some kind of internal connection
VPC and all those stuff. But the point
is the URL itself is different in both
these environments. Similarly, if you
use a email provider, then in
development, you might use something
like a sandbox API so that the emails go
from some kind of test email. If we look
at object storage, if you are using S3,
then in local you might use a locally
running menu instance, while in
production, you'd use an actual AWS S3
instance. For radius, same in local
you'd use a container. in production an
actual radius instance. So in all of
this the only thing that is changing is
the config. Now comes the question why
keep these parts outside of your code
and how do you actually decide whether
these parts should be part of your
codebase should be part of your logic or
it should be in your config. And if you
go through the document, the factors
document, they give a very interesting
test, very useful test which says, can
you open source your codebase, your
production codebase, your internal
codebase of your company right now at
this moment without compromising a
single credential. It's not asking will
you do it. It's it's asking can you do
it given a challenge even for a minute
let's say. So you can take that question
and you can apply it on your codebase
and see what is the answer. If the
answer is no then some kind of config is
sitting inside your code which it should
not be. Okay. Now that part is decided
that config should live outside the
code. But where exactly outside and the
factor says that environment variables
and it gives a few reasons. First,
because environment variables are very
easy to change between different deploys
without you touching a file. Second,
they cannot be checked into the
repository code itself by accident,
which is exactly how credentials get
leaked every single day. And on top of
that, environment variables are a
standard that is part of the operating
system itself. they are not something
which is affected by any programming
language or any framework. So the same
mechanism that you have for environment
variables, it will work for a Go
program, a NodeJS program or a Rust
program, a Python program or even a very
simple bash script as compared to the
alternatives that were existing in those
times. For example, Java had these
things called properties files. Ruby on
Rails had config/database.yiml.
Every framework they had their own
format and pretty much all of them at
some point or another they used to get
committed into the source control and
credentials used to get leaked. If we
look at our own codebase, one of the
code bases that we wrote for one of the
videos in this channel which is called
tasker which is a task management app.
If you look inside the config package,
it declares the whole configuration the
whole configuration as one gostruct the
server block the database block
authentication radius the email
integration AWS observability chron a
block for each one of them. So in total
there are like 38 config values and all
of them are loaded from the environment
variable and we also have a prefix
called tasker. Tasker server port,
tasker database host and so on. And in
the G tree also it will show that the
configs themselves they got changed a
lot of times while the application was
getting developed when we were adding
new integrations or new timeouts, new
hosts. But the code that reads all these
values that barely changed. That is
exactly what the factor expects which is
config should keep changing across
different deployments across time but
the code should not things which have
two different rates of change they
should not live in one place. In the
2011 version of the document it warns
that you should not group configs into
named environments. For example, config/
environment/staging.rb
then production.rb and so on for
development test staging production etc.
Why? Because it does not scale when you
keep adding more and more environments.
For example, let's say someone needs a
new deployment that is almost like
staging but they need to point at a
different database. let's say for a PR
branch and because of that every time
someone adds a new deployment a new
environment you keep adding more and
more code as compared to what the factor
says that the config should be
individual and granular and each one
should be an independent environment
variable and it should never correlate
with the mode names and you should
always compose a new deployment by
setting the values not by choosing what
mode it is turning in. And in the
rewrite also in the modern version also
it says that environment variables are
granular controls and they should never
be grouped together as environments. Now
comes the controversial part here for
environment variables which is
environment variables are a very good
use case or a very good medium when we
are talking about something like a
database host name. But what about the
password? are environment variables
still a very good candidate for a um
high security credential like a database
password. So in 2017 Dio Monica who used
to run security stuff at Docker wrote a
very famous article in that it says that
you should not use environment variables
for password. Why? Because the
environment leaks eventually. For
example, if your app starts new child
processes inside that, then each one of
them will inherit the whole environment.
So if you trigger some kind of shell
command, then all your secrets will go
there will get leaked there. In tools
like crash reporters or uh debug pages,
they have this pattern where they print
the whole environment since it is a
debugging environment. On top of that,
if you are using Linux, the environment
of a particular process is completely
readable depending uh the person has the
right access at proc
and there are various tools that also
log it. So the right pattern here when
it comes to secure credentials is there
should be a separate secret manager
service and your app reads all those
sensitive credentials from the secret
manager when it is starting up when it
is booting and it keeps all of that in
memory not in a separate place in the
operating system. So where do we stand
here? The core advice of the factor
which is the config should strictly be
separated from the code that itself is
non-negotiable. It was non-negotiable
then and it is still non-negotiable and
the prescribed mechanism which is
environment variables that is the right
default especially for everything that
is not a secret that is not a high
security credential but if you are
dealing with secrets if you're dealing
with credentials that should not be the
default all all the time. Of course, if
you are working uh solo or if you are
working in a very small team, then uh
any kind of environment variables that
are injected by your uh platform's
secret feature that can be fine. I mean
that is obviously better than keeping
the credentials committed in the
repository. But as you grow the product,
as you grow your company, as more people
join your company, the no-brainer path
is always a secret manager for all your
credentials. Something like vault or if
you are using AWS, something like
parameter store. During the starting
phase of your application, you will
fetch all those credentials and you will
store it in memory and periodically you
will rotate those credentials and you
will also audit them in all those best
practices. When it comes to security
factor four, treat backing services as
attached resources. What is a backing
service? Backing service is anything
that your application consumes over the
network for doing any kind of operation.
If we look at our day-to-day tech stack,
then our database something like a
posgress service that is a backing
service. Similarly, your radius instance
or your uh Q your background service or
your SMTP service that sends your emails
or your object storage service something
like S3 which you use to store your
files or any third party API like a
payment provider. So if your app talks
to it over the network through some
protocol then it is called a backing
service. Now what is the rule? Your
codebase should not make any distinction
between a backing service that you run
and a backing service that is run by
someone else some other company to your
app. All of them should be treated as an
attached resource which is reachable
through a resource handle. What is a
resource handle? A resource handle is uh
basically the URL plus the credentials.
And in the previous factor we have
already discussed that this thing should
live in your config not in your code. So
simply speaking what this rule is saying
that it does not matter whether you are
running your database inside a container
your radius instance inside your local
container or AWS your posgress inside a
local container or AWS RDS. You should
not give any special treatment in your
code to handle that. The code should be
the same. Does not matter what service
that you're using and which environment
that you're using. The only thing that
should change is the resource handle
itself. Resource handle means the URL to
connect to that resource plus whatever
credentials that come with it. And to
test this pattern inside the codebase in
the 2011 text of the 12 factors document
they give you this test where they say
that which I already mentioned you
should be able to switch your local
posgress URL by any of the managed
service let's say something like neon or
planet scale or superbase anything or
even Amazon RDS without changing a
single line of code. The only thing that
should change is the resource handle in
your config, not your code. If that is
true, then your application sticks to
this factor. So what exactly does this
resource handle that we keep talking
about looks like? If we take a posgress
resource handle, this is what it looks
like which has five parts. First the
scheme which says posgris to imply that
it speaks the posgress wire protocol.
Then comes the credentials user and
password. Then the host then the port
which the default port is 5432.
Then comes the database name. So this
one string it has everything our
application needs to attach this
resource or to talk to this resource to
communicate with this resource. In 2011,
this factor was considered very
eccentric when these Heroku people said
that the database is somebody else's
computer and your app just communicates
to it using a URL which is true even
during those times but that was not the
standard. The standard was still that
for most people the server and the
database both of them were running in
the same machine. So this idea that your
database lives somewhere else than your
server this was not something people
could relate to. Fast forward to a
decade and a half. This is one of the
most common patterns that we see in
every single codebase. In fact, your
server and database running in the same
server instance is considered a
antiattern when it comes to scaling.
Does not matter what database that you
use whether RDS or neon planet scale or
even other services like for radius also
we use managed red instance. For object
storage we use S3 for emails instead of
custom SMTP service used managed
services like resend. So this factor
aged very well. In fact this was kind of
a prediction compared to how the world
was running during those times. Then
factor five strictly separate build and
run stages. To understand this we have
to talk a little bit about CI/CD
pipelines. What typically happens in a
pipeline? Roughly speaking there is
stage one which is called build. In this
stage, the pipeline, the runner, the
program that is trying to build your
application, trying to deploy your
application, it takes your code by doing
some kind of gitpool or some transfer
operation at a particular commit since
that is how deployments work these days.
It does not happen through FTP or file
transfer through SSH or anything.
Everything happens through source
control which means commits are the
primary drivers of any deployment or
build. So for a specific commit we pull
the code for that commit. We fetch all
the dependencies from the manifest file
which we mentioned in factor 2. Then
comes the compiling phase if it is a
compiled language. then we produce one
executable bundle or executable binary
in the document if you see this binary
this bundle is called a build. So if it
is a compiled language like uh something
like go then it is a single binary but
if it is a interpreted language
something like a nodejs app then it is
the whole app plus its node modules
which it needs to run. So in the
container world in the docker world this
is an image and the key property here is
a build should only contain the code and
its dependencies. It should not contain
the configuration the config that we
talked about. Then comes stage two which
is release which takes the build the
binary the bundle which got produced in
the previous stage in stage one. Then it
combines that with the deployments
config depending on which deployment it
is whether it is staging or production
or test or a particular PR preview
whatever deployment it is for that
deployment's config and the result that
we get from these two is what we call a
release. So an exact build plus the
exact config that is ready to run. So a
build combined with our production
config is our production release. Same
build combined with our staging config
is our staging release. Then the last
stage which is the run phase. What does
it do? It takes the previous result
which is the build the binary plus the
config and it starts it launches a
process from that release. That's a
whole rough mapping of what a CI/CD
pipeline does. But why exactly does this
factor exist? Why are we being so strict
about uh separating these stages? There
are primarily two benefits. The first,
since a release is just a build plus a
different config, the builds themselves
are immutable, which means if you want
to do any kind of roll backs, then that
costs you nothing and it is instant. The
document also says that the releases
they should be an appendon ledger, which
means they should not be modified, they
should not be updated, they should only
get appended every time. And every
release should have an ID, a timestamp
or some kind of incrementing number and
a release should not be changed once it
is created. If you want to imagine a
scenario, let's say in the afternoon for
your codebase, you build at commit 97
with the current config and you push a
release which is release number 100.
Then after 2 hours someone rotates the
database password for some reason. So
the config changed then that becomes a
new release which is 101 which has the
same build for the code itself but the
config is new. Similarly, after 2 hours
again you deploy some new code, you make
some new changes or you merge some new
PRs. Then you push release number 102
which changes your build itself not the
config. But once you push that release
which is 102, you see in your dashboard
that there are a lot of 405 errors in
your dashboard and some of your users
are complaining in your Slack channel.
So instead of trying to debug in your
production what exactly is going wrong
while your customers are screaming in
your Slack channel, what you do, you
rerun the release for 101. The release
which was working fine before you pushed
your new code. And since we said that
builds themselves are immutable, that
release only takes a few seconds to go
live. Once your production is back to
stable, you take the bad build, the bad
release and you try to debug by taking
your own time. Does not matter how long
it takes. And the only thing that made
this possible, this whole workflow of
fixing a production instant in just a
few seconds is because of the property
of an ideal build which is being
immutable. The release 101 still means
the same thing. It meant when it was
released 2 hours before the meaning of
that release, the effect, the
consequences of that release never
changes because it is immutable. The
same build and the same config. Every
platform that we knows these days which
uses the same patterns whether it is
Heroku releases, Docker image tags or a
Kubernetes rollout all of them. Now the
second benefit if code only enters the
pipeline at the build stage it means
that no one even if they try can edit
the code on production server because
there is no path from the running
machine back into the build as compared
to the snowflake server world that we're
talking about in the start of this
video. logging into the server using SSH
and doing a hot patch and reloading your
server. That practice was very common
and that is exactly what used to cause
the production environment and the code
repository itself having two different
states eventually. So strict separation
of the builds makes that situation
impossible to happen. In the modern
rewrite, it only adds one change to this
factor to the original 2011 factor which
is immutable which was implied in the
2011 version but now it is part of the
principle. It is mandatory. So each
release should be a unique and immutable
snapshot. Factor six execute the app as
one or more stateless processes. Which
means your app should run as different
different processes who do not remember
anything between two different requests
which is the statelessness property
which we have been discussing in pretty
much every other video since the start
of this playlist. The statelessness
property of our back end of our service
is something that helps us scale. In the
document it says share nothing between
these two process which means do not
share memory or disk also. Whatever that
needs to get persisted, it should go in
a stateful backing service which from
the factor 4 we have already discussed
that it should be an attached resource
and you should always treat your service
with the expectation that any request at
any point can be served by any of the
processes and any of the process can
disappear at any moment. they can be
destroyed at any moment. So is the
process allowed to hold anything? Are
there any exceptions? So the document
says memory and local disk are fine as a
cache for one transaction. Similarly, if
you want to download a file, process it
and you want to write the result to the
database, then the temp file, temporary
file that you used to store it while you
are processing the file, that is fine.
Why? Because after that transaction,
nothing else expects that to be there.
It is just one time. And since it is in
a temporary directory that is anyway
going to disappear at any moment in any
situation. If you expect that a future
request or a future process is going to
depend on the presence of the file then
that is where it becomes problematic
otherwise it's fine. The document also
mentions a very famous issue which is
called sticky sessions. Sticky session
basically means that the load balancer
that is in front of your API service, it
remembers which instance a user should
land on every time based on their past
activity and it makes sure that the user
is repeatedly routed to the same
instance every time so that whatever in
process state that you are depending on
it keeps working. It does not break. So
what kind of scenarios? Let's say your
application stores the logged in user
session in process memory. So it works
perfectly in one instance. Then if you
have watched the scaling video after
that let's say you scale your instance
to three different instances to handle
your load and you place all of them
behind a load balancer and a user logs
in to instance number one. In the next
request, they get routed to instance
number two. And since instance number
two has never heard of this user, since
you are storing the session in process
memory, it throws some kind of error and
the user is instantly logged out
randomly. So the the loophole, the
workaround people came up with to get
around of this issue is making the load
balancer remember which user goes to
which instance based on their past
requests. and they make sure they get
routed to that every time. That is what
we call a sticky session and this
document it as you can expect is pretty
against it. It states that sticky
session a violation and they should
never be used no matter what the
situation is. Why? Because the property
of being sticky, the property of
sticking to one instance at the load
balancer level, it completely defeats
the whole purpose of having three
instances in the first place. Why? If
you kill one instance or one of the
instances get killed because of some
traffic load or because of some
corruption then all the users instantly
get logged out or in the next response
and if to handle your traffic load you
add another instance then that does not
get any existing users. People have to
start over again. They have to start
from login flow again. So what is the
fix for this? Session data is a type of
state and we already know every state
goes into a backing service which means
you should put your session behind
something like radius or posgress or
your database whatever makes you
comfortable and based on your latency
requirements. Now if you remember the
real time video where we talked about
the process having state when we
discussed websockets. Now a web socket
is a state which stays in the process
memories which exactly breaks this
property of the statelessness and this
factor that we are currently discussing
and in that video we discussed that the
instance that is holding the socket in
that process memory that is the only
instance in the world that the user who
is connected through websocket can talk
to and to get around that problem what
we did we made use of a publish and
subscribe system so that after every
event we publish it and any other
instance that the user is connected to
they can subscribe to it and register to
the changes. So where does that land us?
If we are talking about realtime systems
if we are talking about websockets then
the statelessness property is kind of a
violation there. So in those situations
in my opinion the factor this factor
that we are discussing about of being
stateless this is a default you apply it
everywhere but you are allowed to break
it when the feature that we are talking
about in this case real time or
websockets that feature itself is the
state then I guess we are allowed to
break it. So what is the thumb rule
here? If you cannot kill any process or
any instance at any moment without a
user losing their data, then you have a
state where it does not belong. That is
the thumb rule for this factor. Okay. So
far, where do we stand? The 12 factor
app is a contract between your
application and the platform that runs
it. And what are the things we have
learned so far? What are the
capabilities that we have achieved so
far? Your code stays in one repository.
All its dependencies, all its needs need
to be declared beforehand and they need
to be isolated. All the differences
should live in the environment. All its
neighbors, all its backing services,
they should be attached through handles.
The way to take it to production is
through build, then release, then run.
And the ideal way to run it is as a
disposable and forgetful process. Six
factors. And you can already see the
kind of capabilities, the kind of
freedom our service has already
acquired. Now let's get to the last six.
Factor seven. Export services via port
binding. Now this will sound way too
obvious for you but again we have to
look at the historical angle. In 2011 a
lot of people were working on PHP. It
was like the React during those times.
So the PHP app itself did not run. What
actually ran was Apache and the PHP app
was a module which was loaded inside
Apache. Similarly, a Java app did not
run itself. A server called Tomcat used
to run and the Java app was a file which
is put inside the Tomcats folder. So the
pattern was the web server Apache Tomkit
these were the famous web servers. They
were the programs and our applications
they were just a guest inside the
running program which meant that the web
server's version and its configuration
was part of our application's runtime
environment which is part of the
physical server. So we are back to the
erosion area again. That is exactly what
this factor is trying to prevent which
says your app should be completely
self-contained which means it should
bring its own HTTP server as a library
and how should it bring it from the
factor 2's dependency manifest that we
discussed and it should export itself as
a service by binding to a port and
listening for connections from there.
But if you notice how services work
these days in 2026, that is the most
obvious pattern. Every backend app,
every service that we run, it binds
itself to a port. Uh for example, in go
one of the common ports are 8080. For
NodeJS also, we use something like 4,000
or whatever port that is free.
Similarly, databases also bind
themselves to a default port as a
service. So during development you just
directly access your service through
localhost col 80080 and in production
there is usually a routing layer. You
have your reverse proxy which forwards
the public host name to whatever port
your process is binding itself to. And
one of the convenient consequences that
we achieve with this pattern is if you
export your service just by binding it
to a port then any app can become a
backing service for any other app. That
is exactly how we run and scale our
services these days. Our database binds
itself to some port. Our cache binds
itself to some port. Our emailing
service binds itself to some port.
everything in local host and the moment
we go to production we just replace
those URLs those handles with production
URLs which binds those services to
someone else's port in someone else's
computer in the cloud but the same logic
the same pattern throughout so what aged
here one of those things is serverless
because a lambda function if you're
aware of lambda functions in AWS they do
not bind themselves to a port the
platform The running platform calls a
function that you export through code.
In 2011, the services binding themselves
to a port and running 24/7 that was
predicted as a pattern that will persist
throughout. But of course that did not
happen. That is one of the patterns, one
of the most used patterns. But these
days we also have other patterns. we
have a completely different category of
running service which is called
serverless architecture where there is
no concept of a longunning portbound
server. So that is why in the rewrite of
this factor if you see they have kept
the port binding thing as a headline but
they have also tried to include
serverless architecture by mentioning
that the app should be self-contained
and it should export its service through
a declared interface. So that the same
principle applies to both a longunning
portbound server and also serverless
infrastructure which is just an exported
function run by the platform. Now factor
eight scale out via the process model.
Going back to the 2011 times, how did
apps exactly scale? Which means what
changes people needed to make on the
apps so that they could take more
traffic load, more user load at any
point if some kind of traffic spike
happened. And every runtime, every
language had its own scaling mechanism.
For example, if you looked at Java, the
way it scaled was it was a huge process
in itself, the JVM, the Java runtime
itself. And during the startup, it used
to take a huge block of memory, huge
block of RAM. And then it used to
multiplex inside itself, inside its own
runtime with threads. That's how it used
to scale. PHP was the opposite of that.
The Apache server on top of which PHP
used to run it used to spin small child
process on demand. That's how it used to
scale. So the factor says that you
should keep the process as a first class
citizen and you design your services you
design your backends in a way that they
can be scaled as different different
processes from the scratch instead of
doing it on demand and the whole
architecture was inspired from our Unix
the Linux operating system course
service model or service demons and it
prescribes different kinds of process
types because different kinds of work
should get different types of process.
For example, if you are dealing with
HTTP requests, then that should be
categorized as a web process. Similarly,
if we are talking about heavy background
jobs, for example, video encoding, image
resizing and all these things, then
those kinds of jobs should go to worker
process. Similarly, if you have a
scheduleuler, let's say a email should
be sent to every one of your users at
12:00 in the night, which is a
scheduleuler logic. So that should get
its own process type. Then once you have
different different process for
different different kinds of jobs, they
should scale independently of each
other. How? By running their own copies.
Let's say each of your process they take
500 MB of RAM roughly speaking and let's
say your product it is a food delivery
product then when it is lunch time
obviously people will order more as
compared to let's say sometime around
10:00 or 11:00 so during lunchtime your
traffic your user load needs 10 web
processes to deal with all the requests
but your queue only needs two processes
because the the worker jobs that is not
as heavy during lunchtime as compared to
the number of requests that you're
getting. But if those two different
kinds of jobs were part of one process,
they were part of one big process. Then
if you wanted to scale your web process
during lunchtime to deal with all these
requests which you anyway have to it
means that you scale your big process
into 10 different copies which means the
workers also got scaled to 10 copies. So
your 5GB of web process because each one
takes 500 MB they are doing their work
they are appropriately scaled but the
5GB extra of the worker process that got
scaled because they were part of the web
process they are not really doing any
kind of work. So when you split those
when you run them as their own process
during lunchtime you can scale your web
process to 10 while keeping the workers
to two. So now instead of 10 GB you're
only using 6GB of your server's
resources. Then when it's night time
usually during the night we run all our
cues all our workers. So the number of
requests which the web process deals
with that gets reduced a little because
during night not a lot of people order
food. So during that time you keep the
web process to let's say five and you
scale your workers to 20 because you
have a lot of background jobs to run. So
this process of setting the type and
count of process let's say the web
equals to three and the worker equals
two. This whole process, this whole
architecture, this whole mechanism is
called the process formation which is
something that we still use in our
vocabulary. If you check any proc file
and any Kubernetes deployment spec there
we write replicas colon 3 that is what
we call as a process formation and we
write it in YAML these days. some notes
here which is the process model the
process they do not really forbid you
from using threads if you are inside
your process if you're inside one
process then you're free to do any kind
of multiplexing you want to you can use
threads in the JVM you can use go
routines in your go app you can use
event loop in your node app but the
point is whenever we are talking about
scaling the unit of the scale should be
the process not the threads or the go
routines or the event loop. Why? Because
one machine can only grow so far before
you run out of your uh limit of vertical
scaling. So if you have this model which
says share nothing then that can be
scaled across multiple machines without
thinking twice. The second note is a 12
factor app. If you're saying our
application is 12 factor and it should
be then it in itself should never
demonize it should never write to a P
file. Why? Because the managing the
process it since it is the process
itself it should not be involved in any
kind of process management job or any
kind of process life cycle workflow.
Managing the process lifetime that is
the platform's job. If you are running
on top of operating system directly then
that is the operating systems job. If
you are running in Kubernetes then it is
Kubernetes job or your process manager's
job. Your app just runs in the
foreground and it does its work and you
let the platform do its own job of
running you as a process. So what aged
here which is the orchestrators these
days pretty much the whole internet does
not matter what cloud platform that you
are using most of them run on top of
Kubernetes or Kubernetes or any other
kind of orchestrators not necessarily
Kubernetes but the logic of
orchestrators the mechanism of
orchestrators where you just declare a
formation and the platform which is
running it it maintains it it kills
containers it starts containers it
restarts it reboots all those life cycle
things. You do not really think about
any of these. So it's not that the
factor got outdated. It's just it got
adopted so deeply so hard that we do not
really need to think about this unless
of course you are deploying your
application directly on top of a
operating system using systemd. In that
case it still applies. Maximize
robustness with fast startup and
graceful shutdown which demands that
your process should be disposable which
means they should be built in a way that
they can be started or stopped at a
moment's notice and nothing bad nothing
destructive should happen in both the
cases and in video 19 I think we talked
a lot about graceful shutdown the whole
life cycle of that so I will move fast
here and if you want to cover the depth
you can refer to that video but why are
we talking about uh the property of
disposability if you look at who
actually starts and stops your process
these days if you are trying to scale if
you're trying to horizontally scale it
means new process get started any moment
or if you are doing any kind of
deployment then old process they get
killed and new process started from the
new container image they replace the old
ones. So the platform which is running
the orchestrator whatever it is that
moves process it deletes it restarts it
starts between different machines
whenever it likes. So if let's say you
deploy your application five times a
week across 10 different instances that
means 50 times your process are stopped
50 times new ones are started before we
even talk about scaling itself just the
deployment part if you deploy every day
that itself is causing 50 times of
stopping and starting. So a process
dying is not an unnatural thing anymore.
It is part of our development life
cycle. It is part of our release life
cycle. It is not what we consider as an
incident anymore. That is the
justification for why they should be
disposable. Why the killing itself
should be fast. Similarly, if the
startup is slow, if your program takes a
long time to start, then every one of
those 100 events that we talked about,
they themselves are slow. So if it takes
60 seconds to boot your process to start
your process then when your orchestrator
is doing a rolling deploy of let's say
10 instances then it takes 10 minutes
and if you have an autoscaler it will
become 1 minute late for any kind of
traffic spike. If they only take 2
seconds then it is almost negligible. So
the factor also demands that your
startup your boot time should only be a
few seconds. Similarly when we are
talking about shutdown especially
graceful shutdown that is where it it is
coming from. If your shutdown does not
really think about how it is shutting
down, if it is not graceful, if it is
careless in how it is shutting down,
then all the in-flight requests, all the
things that is currently doing before it
shuts down, let's say it is doing some
kind of background processing, at that
point when the shutdown request comes,
it is processing five different HTTP
requests. If it does not finish
processing all the requests and if it
does not follow a particular life cycle
of uh finishing the existing work then
stopping to take any new work and then
stopping the process and all these uh
things that we discuss in the graceful
shutdown part then all the in-flight
requests they suddenly get errors when
you do any kind of deployment. So as we
discussed in the graceful shutdown video
whenever we receive the term signal the
web process the process which is
responsible for processing all the
requests it stops accepting new requests
and it finishes whatever requests it's
already processing then it exits. There
is a life cycle it has to follow so that
the existing users they certainly do not
get errors. That's exactly what our go
app does on a server shutdown.
Similarly, what does a graceful shutdown
mean for a worker process. Naturally,
the graceful part is it should be able
to return the current job back to the
queue. Instead of discarding it, it
should return back to the queue because
uh it is time to shut down. And when we
say that it should be able to return it
back to the queue, we are also assuming
a property which will make the next run
possible which is called a re-entrancy
property. What that means is the job
which was currently running and because
of the shutdown it had to return back to
the queue when it leaves the processing
it should not leave any dirty state. It
should not do any operation which when
performed again will cause issues. And
how do you get this re-entry property?
By either wrapping the whole processing
inside a transaction or you can make the
operation itself as item potent which
means it does not matter how many times
you run a particular code snippet it
will always produce the same result. So
if by mistake it was processed twice
then it is still safe. It does not do
any kind of operation twice. It is able
to detect that and it is able to skip
that. That is what we call as item
important. Then we get to the part where
it says that it should also be robust
against sudden death. Why? Because sig
term our application getting the sig
term signal from our platform from our
runtime from our orchestrator that is a
polite case. That is the case that we
are prepared to handle where we get
around 30 seconds or so so that we can
clean up, wrap up whatever that we are
doing and we can exit gracefully. That
is why it's called graceful exit. We are
given a time so that you can wrap up
whatever you are doing and then you
exit. But what happens when some kind of
hardware failure happens? Let's say your
process tries to acquire way too much of
a memory and the container gets killed
because of the out of memory error. It
does not really send a warning in that
situation. It just suddenly kills your
container and in turn kills your
process. So we need to design in a way
that any process can be shut down mid
instruction any time. So the document
also points at uh this particular design
which is called a crash only design
which says that if you are able to
survive crashes then you do not really
need a graceful shutdown path at all
because the crash path itself is the
shutdown path. Factor 10 keep
development staging and production as
similar as possible and uh in the
industry we call it as dev/road parity.
Parity just means uh sameness how
similar they are. In the document it
mentions that in between development and
production there are three major gaps.
First one is the time gap which means
that if you are writing some code today
then it reaches production maybe on
Friday or maybe next week and when we
actually do that deployment it's not
just your code a lot of code gets merged
at the same time. So the time gap also
brings a lot of changes at once. Then
the personal gap which means that the
person who writes the code is not always
necessarily the same person who deploys
the code and same way it's not the
person who sees the error who is the
operations person and then the tools gap
during development we either use
something like a MacBook or a Windows
machine which is running its own
completely different stack whether
Docker containers or native
installations on Mac OS or Windows as
compared to what we are learning in our
production which is a Linux machine
which is connected to external servers,
external backing services. So the whole
architecture is completely different and
a lot of times that difference causes a
lot of bugs. So the document has this
table which shows traditional app versus
the 12 factor app. So instead of
deploying every week or every 2 weeks,
you deploy every few hours. Similarly,
instead of different people writing the
code and different people deploying the
code versus the same people who write
the code, they are the ones who deploy
the code. So they are the ones who will
look at the log lines whenever some
error happens. Similarly, instead of
having different different environments
in local, in production, in staging, you
try to keep the environments as same as
possible. So if you shrink all the gaps
one by one, the process of continuous
deployment becomes extremely smooth. The
other gaps are something that are
already closed to a lot of extent these
days. But the tools gap that is
something that still exists. For
example, whenever we do uh some kind of
database operation during development,
there is this practice where people use
a lightweight database instead of a full
posgress. Let's say something like
SQLite. Why and how? Because we have
these OMS. If you are in NodeJS, you
have OMS like Drizzle, Prisma. If you
are in Go, you have OM like Gorm. If you
are in Python, you have SQL Alchemy. So
all these OMS they enable you this
feature that you do not really need to
worry about the database unless it's a
very specific niche case where you are
writing raw SQL queries and using the OM
as just a database driver. But most of
the times the database gets completely
abstracted and you use the OM's own
standards, the OM's own practices, its
own patterns to write the code, to write
the database code and the OM takes care
of what database that you are connecting
to behind the scenes. It can be possite,
it can be MySQL. So the OMS make it very
convenient to use this pattern. But
there are of course a lot of issues when
you are using SQLite in your development
and posgress in your production. For
example, in Postgress, the like operator
is case sensitive and I like operator is
the case insensitive version. But in
SQLite like is case insensitive by
default for ASKI characters. So if you
have implemented some kind of search
feature in your local using your SQLite
database through your OM and you push
that to production that is going to
break someday because of the assumption
that you have made and you are not aware
of the assumptions or you are not aware
of this distinction between the like
operators in the both databases. And the
dangerous part here is you do not really
get any error or any kind of warning or
any kind of logs. It just completely
changes the behavior. So the the advice
here from the document is the backing
services either the database or the
cache or the Q whatever backing services
that you're using it should be the same
in local environment in staging
environment and in production
environment. And especially in these
times that is not really an excuse
because it just takes one command to
start a container in your local and
start communicating with it. It is not
as much of a hassle as it used to be
during 2011 when this factor was
created. But in 2026 it is not as clean
also. I mean of course we started with
Docker and um for some period of time
the local environment and the production
environment used to be the same because
of the whole Docker and Docker Compose
ecosystem and us using the same
container in both the environments. But
eventually we started moving to managed
services. For example, in production, if
you use Dynamob, AWS Dynamob, then there
is no way to run Dynamob in your local.
Of course, there are emulations uh and
similar implementations which try to
emulate as many behaviors as possible
for Dynamob. For example, the popular
platform called local stack. it it
enables you to use a lot of AWS services
in your local but it is not the same
implementation because AWS is Dynamob it
is proprietary and whatever you learn
about the behavior is from the
documented ones so you cannot really
replicate the exact technology in your
local so that does create some gap and
there is no straightforward advice here
that you should not go for managed
services and you should try to keep the
environment same in local production.
You cannot say that because managed
services they do offer a lot of
advantages a lot of uh convenience when
it comes to scaling your services when
it comes to keeping your cost down by
not running your own infrastructure. So
the the nuanced takeaway from this is if
the benefit of using a managed service
with the trade-off of having two
distinct environments in your local
versus in production. If the benefits
are huge, the benefits are large then we
should definitely go for that. Factor
11, treat logs as event streams. One of
the first things that come to our mind
whenever we are talking about logs
because of the way logs were treated
historically is a log file. But in this
factor the document says that the file
was never really the log. The file is
just one of the output formats. The log
itself is a stream of events which are
ordered by time and they will keep
flowing. The events will keep flowing.
the log events will keep flowing as long
as your application runs and there is no
beginning to that and there is no end to
that. It is directly related to your
application running. So once you start
treating logs as just a stream instead
of uh imagining them as an output format
either standard output or a file or some
kind of log drain which is an external
service if you just think about them as
a stream then you'll get the intuition
of this factor which says that your 12
factor app should not get involved in
the routing or storing of that stream.
You just have to make sure that there is
a log stream. It should not worry about
log file paths or uh rotating the log
files or anything like that which goes
outside of the scope of treating logs as
a stream. So what it prescribes your
application writes every single event
every single log event to your standard
output which means uh if you are running
your application in your terminal
whatever output that you see right after
running your application that is what we
call as standard output. So that's what
it proves that always publish your logs,
always stream your logs without keeping
any kind of buffer. It should be
unbuffered to the standard output and
the execution environment, the execution
uh platform, the orchestrator, whatever
platform that you are running on top of.
It is that platform's responsibility to
capture that stream and then decide
where it goes. Whether it goes to a file
or whether it goes to a backing service
which is a log drain for further
analysis or storing it's that platform's
job. And why do we have this division?
Why do we have this factor? There are
two reasons. First, you do not need to
worry about your logging needs while
deploying your application because it is
not the responsibility of your
application anymore. So no code gets
changed every time you decide to deploy
your application in a different
environment. It is the job of your
config now. So in 2011 when this factor
was prescribed all the standard output
log used to go to something like SIS log
and these days in production all our
standard output logs go to something
like Loki or data dog depending on your
uh architecture. But the pattern is
still the same. Second, a stream is
something that you can compose with
other parts but you cannot do the same
thing for files. What that means is if
we talk about three different
environments on your laptop when you are
running your application your log stream
since you are pushing it to standard
output you see all your logs in your
terminal and you are able to read it
live. Similarly, if you are in a
container, then the runtime will be able
to capture those logs, those stream and
it will be able to stamp those logs by
which process exactly is that log coming
from and then it gives that back to the
collector whichever collector process is
trying to store that log, trying to uh
analyze that log or whatever. Similarly,
in your production environment, the
platform, the orchestrator or whatever
cloud platform, it takes all the streams
of all your instances. Then it merges
them into one log stream which is
ordered by time. So you do not have to
make the distinction of which log is
coming from which instance. You just
have to worry about the time of when
each event happened. So the whole
overhead of um worrying about
understanding your logs, analyzing your
logs, searching in your logs when there
are multiple instances that is
completely gone because of this
architecture. So by just pushing your
logs into standard output, you can
compose different different
architectures from the same pattern
depending on the environment. But these
days of course we have much more
advanced architectures when it comes to
logs. We have this whole field of study
or field of technology called
observability which consists of logs,
metrics and traces. But in the original
2011 text, it only mentions logs because
the other two the metrics and traces
that was not something that was
practiced during those times. So you
have to take the practice of metrics,
traces and all these new things as an
addition instead of uh thinking that the
factor itself is limiting you. And now
factor 12 run admin and management tasks
as oneoff process. What is a one-off
process? It basically means a task that
you only run once and it is run next to
the uh your application's long running
process and then it exits. So let's
imagine a scenario you have a back end
an HTTP back end which um takes as usual
HTTP requests and processes and gives
back responses. Apart from doing that it
also needs to do other stuff. For
example, it needs to run a database
migration or maybe it needs to run a uh
some kind of script to fix some kind of
data in your production. So these kinds
of things which run exactly once and
they need to run side by side to your
running application. So this factor
talks about where exactly we should run
these one-off process, one-off tasks.
And it says that a one-off process, a
one of admin process, it should run in
an identical environment to your
original application's regular process.
It should have the same codebase and it
should exist in the same commit so that
the deployment can take both and it
should also work with the same config
and the same dependency isolation model
that applies to our original
application. And why are we being so
strict about this uh one-off script
one-off process? Because in the old days
when people wanted to fix a particular
record, they used to do an SSH into
their running server and they used to
run a query either update query or a
delete query or some query and there was
no process of any kind of code review or
the process review, no record, no logs
of what exactly did you do in production
which causes a lot of drift between your
production environment and what exist in
your code, what is documented. One of
the most famous examples which follows
this factor is our database migrations
which ships with our same code and it
runs as a one-off process before our
application starts and it ends there. to
show some of these 12 factors in
practice. This is our task app that we
built in one of our videos and this is
the back end of that which is running in
a Linux machine a hawk that we are
sshing into and it is driven by a proc
file which is just a file that was
invented by Heroku to declare different
process types. the different process
types that we talked about web process
worker process and then scheduuling
process and so on. So one process type
which is web then a process manager
called overmind which starts the whole
formation and if you look at the booting
process there is this schema check then
the background job server and then the
server binds itself to the port it was
assigned to everything that we talked
about in the factors in that exact
order. Then it also has its own log
stream which is going to standard
output. Now in the second pane I'm
running a one-off admin process which is
uh for autoarchchiving which runs from
the same code the same config and the
same environment and then it exits and
in the end we press Ctrl C and if you
look at the shutdown the connection pool
closes the job server waits for all its
workers to finish their jobs and the
process reports a clean exit is the
factor 8 9 and Elsewhere